في واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيو بلينكن ان لدى تركيا هواجس امنيه
مشروعه اذا انضمام السويد في لندن
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع نظيره الفنلندي
والسويدي في واشنطن بالخطوات التي اتخذتها
ستوكهولم وهل سينكي للحد من مخاوف انقره
الامنيه
منذ اليوم الاول لطالب انضمام السويد
وفنلندا الى النيترو هناك ارهابيه على
الاراضي تركيا اكثر من اي بلد اخر في حلف
الناتو لكن انا نقدر الخطوات الملموسه
التي اتخذتها في الاندلس السويد بما فيها
تعزيز التعاون الثنائي بشكل كبير مع تركيا
بشان مخاوفها الامنيه الرئيسيه تمضي هذه
العمليه قدما بفضل العمل المهم للغايه
الذي قامت به في الاندلس السويد مع تركيا
وتوقعوا ان تستمر لعمليه وانت تنتهي بنجاح